Daniel: Hello?
It's February 7, 2023.
We're here in Active Bookstream number
1.09.
Off to you, Bleu.
Bleu: Hi, I'm Bleu Knight.
I am a researcher in New Mexico, and we
are the Active Active Inference
Institute, participatory online institute
that is communicating, learning, and
practicing applied active inference.
You can reach us at our social media
links here.
And just a reminder, this is a recorded
and an archived Livestream.
So please provide us with feedback so
that we can improve on our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here, and we will be following
good video etiquette for live streams.
And just as we're mentioning that all
backgrounds and perspectives are welcome
here, we will be having our final
discussion coming up in about four
weeks.
So if you would really like to
participate, if you've watched some of
the live streams and have some questions,
we would really like to get some outside
perspective.
So please get in touch with us so that
you can participate in our final
discussion.
So, like I said, if you want to
participate, this is how.
And so we are still discussing governing
continuous transformation.
And today our goal is to discuss section
nine.
So, chapter nine.
And we will be doing Bookmap roadmap and
all of the typical things.
So, I already introduced myself.
Daniel just gave us the date.
Why don't you introduce yourself?
Daniel: It's Daniel in California.
I'll pass to Tyler.
Tyler: I'm Tyler in California.
I am a dow researcher and protocol
designer.
All right, Bleu.
Bleu: All right.
So here we are at the end of part two.
So next week, the author is going to join
us for a discussion over part two, the
Free Energy governance section of the
book.
And then we'll be moving into part
three.
I think we're going to do two chapters at
a time as we go through part three.
And I don't think we'll be discussing the
engaged scholarship interviews, but if
you're curious about them, I encourage
you to read the text.
Okay.
Tyler, do you want to read this first
part of the abstract for us?
Tyler: Sure.
All right.
So beneath all chaos is an underlying
structure.
Our challenges to exploit disorder's.
Underlying order survive.
Living organisms are encoded to resist
disorder.
I.
E.
Entropy by way of self organization.
Firms are nothing more than molecules and
are subject to obeying the very same
laws.
Thermodynamics entropy will eventually
rise.
Three specific propositions previously
developed as part of this book's
underlying dissertational research are
outlined.
One structure.
The stronger, affirm's, cross
hierarchical, top down, bottom up
cognitive throughput coupling between and
within governance and operational
channels.
The less dominant, affirm's, top down
approach cultivating a form of CEO
centrism and strategy ownership.
Bleu, you want to take the next one?
Bleu: Yes.
So, two cognition.
The stronger a firm's cognitive
disposition toward environmental
enactment and innovative abduction, as
opposed to adaptation.
The stronger the firm's strategic control
and the smaller the risk of falling for
the financial control trap.
Three capabilities the stronger the
board's dmn centric duality stewardship
empowering upper echelon to sustainably
balance exploitation versus exploration
as well as financial versus strategic
control.
The stronger the sustainability of
successful and continuous strategic
renewal and hence the firm's prospects
for survival.
Strategy is less macroscopic but more
subatomic, less linear and deterministic,
but more quantum and discontinuous.
There is a dominant tendency of
glorifying the realist beauty of top down
linear cause effect relationships to the
very detriment of quantum self
organization.
And I'm going to start off just reading
Thomas Parr from the book so Bijean says,
I'm trying to see it over my screen
order.
Anywhere in the cosmos is so singular.
It always requires an exemplary mechanism
or a process, while randomization
requires no, I can't read the word.
It is simply the way of the world.
When particles are allowed to act
randomly, whether it's the contents of a
glass of club soda on the rocks or the
countless atoms making up the air in the
room they slam into each other,
exchanging energy until complete
randomizations of their positions and
velocities is observed.
And so Bijean quotes this Lanza et al.
2020 paper and I was just like thinking
of firms as organizations of people and
it really brought this picture to mind of
atoms randomly slamming into each other
like people randomly slamming into each
other like the mosh pit versus the board
meeting.
I just wanted to bring this juxtaposition
of what is it to minimize free energy in
terms of assembling humans as opposed to
assembling atoms.
Anyway, I should have to share with this
mental image.
Okay.
Tyler, do you want to read this one for
us?
Tyler: Sure.
So beneath all chaos is an underlying
structure.
Our challenge is to exploit disorders
underlying order to survive.
Living organisms are encoded to resist
disorder I.
E.
Entropy by way of self organization.
Firms are nothing more than molecules and
are subject to bang the very same laws
thermodynamics.
And so yeah, I thought the connection
here that was interesting was comparing
saying that the laws of thermodynamics
apply to firms and that's what's really
going on.
And we talked about this in previous
streams.
I know we have Blues kind of talk about a
little more in detail here but whether
that's more of like an analogy comparing
to thermodynamics or something like a
real underlying structure of
thermodynamics and we'll talk about that
more shortly.
Bleu: That also brings to mind like the
mosh pit.
And I wonder in our base case as humans,
is our natural inclination to be
increasingly chaotic and we override
that?
I don't know.
I had all these mental images as I was
reading this as well.
Yeah, Tyler put this in.
So I love this.
I'm going to read it because I love it.
He actually quotes Gould et al.
2016 in the quote.
He says if physical theories were people
thermodynamics would be the village
witch.
Over the course of three centuries she
smiled quietly as other theories rose.
And withered surviving major revolutions
in physics, like the advent of general
relativity and quantum mechanics, the
other theories find her somewhat odd,
somehow different in nature from the
rest.
Yet everyone comes to her for advice, and
no one dares to contradict her.
Einstein, for instance, called her the
only physical theory of universal
content, which I am convinced that within
the framework of applicability of its
basic concepts will never be overthrown.
Her power and resilience lay mostly on
her frank intentions.
Thermodynamics has never claimed to be a
means to understand the mysteries of the
natural world, but rather a path toward
efficient exploitation of said world.
Yeah.
Do you want to add comments here, Tyler?
Tyler: Yeah, I liked about this was that
the kind of, like, mystical business
leader, like a Steve Jobs character, is
kind of like a trope in the business
world, and it's kind of like almost like
a joke at this point.
But there's also a real case mystical
business leader, which is almost kind of
what I think Dejan is describing here, is
that the real state of the world, of
operating as a firm in a very uncertain
is probably not the word I should use,
but in an ActInf sense, it's a very
mystical, receptive way of engaging with
the world.
And I really like making that connection
of mysticism with business, with
corporations.
Daniel: One other angle there is
organizations are doing work.
They're doing hopefully useful work.
And Thermodynamics is concerned with how
thermal energy that uncorrelated
exchangeable entropic dissipation can be
channeled into moving the steamboat
forward or lifting up the weight on the
crane.
And so sometimes with the amount of
seething activity in formal firms or
informal groups, it's like, but if we all
just went in this exact direction at this
exact time, we could do this.
It's like, well, if all the air molecules
just slammed against the wall, it would
fall over.
Or if they all formed into a droplet,
you'd get rain in the room.
Like Thermodynamics helps us understand
what is likely to happen given those
interacting state spaces.
And again, interestingly, it has to do
with extracting work, useful work from
this background of just vibration.
That's not work.
Tyler: Yeah.
The other thing I like to just to build
on that is it's okay to not know what's
going on is that that doesn't necessarily
need to be a source of stress.
It's just like you can harness those
energies and kind of see which way the
wind is blowing, so to speak, without
necessarily understanding all the
underlying principles.
And that's totally okay.
And I think that's generally something
that gives a lot of people, both in the
business world and even in our personal
lives, a lot of stress.
But this is also, I think, a very freeing
way to approach an uncertain world.
Bleu: Yeah.
Maybe to close the loop or maybe open it
up a little bit more.
There's also the prospect of doing work
that you don't know is going to be
fruitful.
And so that is this uncertainty.
Minimization you could spend your whole
an hour trying to crack open a nut.
And the nut is empty.
That's also possible, right?
So even though you're doing work that may
be useful work, it might not bear fruit.
So there's that uncertainty element as
just a human or also as a firm?
So I just wanted to bring back these
slides while we're talking about
thermodynamics we talked about this a
long time ago, and we talked about the
difference between thermodynamic entropy
and information.
Theoretic entropy?
And so I just wanted to kind of bring
this back and just remind everyone that
there's a difference.
There is relationships between the two
that are still being hashed out, like
mathematically and not totally
understood.
But the second law of thermodynamics is
that this entropy like disorder in the
universe is always increasing.
And here the energy is always lost in a
transfer.
In work, as heat to the environment less
and less usable energy becomes
available.
All Right?
And then in information theory, we kind
of talked about entropy with an inverse
relationship with information.
So here you can see like event that is
low probability is high information.
So if you're decoding a stream of letters
I always like to think about it like this
because it was explained to me like that
and it made so much sense.
If you're decoding a stream of letters
and you're expecting a message.
And this was Claude Shannon and kind of
like how he or how it was explained to me
how he kind of came up with this.
So you're decoding a message and you get
the letters.
Th It would be really freaking weird if
the next letter was Z.
I don't know any words that have THC.
That's a very low probability event.
Right?
So it would be like a very high
information thing.
Or maybe something came before the th and
you missed it.
But there's some probability.
Like th e would be great or like thi.
But thz wouldn't make any sense.
Unless the th was at the end of some
previous word.
And so you can kind of deduce what to
expect in those kinds of situations.
The probability distribution is like when
there's 50 50 probability.
So this is the second graph on the
right.
When there's 50 50 probability.
Like the flip of a fair coin.
That's super high entropy.
Like you don't have any idea if it's
going to be heads or if it's going to be
tails.
But here it's low entropy.
If It's like a Coin with two heads,
there's heads On Both sides.
Like you can only come out with heads.
So there's very low entropy in such a
coin flip because the outcome is always
heads.
Right.
If there's no distinction between the two
sides.
So I don't know that's the thermodynamic
dynamic entropy versus information.
Theoretic entropy.
And I think we talk a lot about
thermodynamic entropy, but maybe forget
that the FEP is really kind of founded in
the information theoretic entropy as
well.
Do you guys have anything to add here?
No?
Okay.
All right, so Bijean makes this claim in
this section, and I'm not going to read
the claim, but I'm just going to point
out that here we kind of have a really
concise definition of like he's been
emphasizing the structure, cognition, and
capabilities for a few chapters now.
And so here he defines structure as the
circular coupling of governance
predictions and operational stimuli
channels in the form of prediction,
error, minimization.
He defines cognition as environmental
engagement in the form of enactment
rather than adaptation.
And he defines capabilities as sensing
and sense making in the form of duality
management.
And so this chapter was really kind of a
good summary chapter, I thought, and kind
of gives us a chance to go back and
revisit a couple of the concepts that we
talked about before, but maybe need to
highlight one more time.
Do you want to read this one, Tyler, for
us?
Tyler: Sure.
So, yeah, through the rest of the
chapter, Bajan is going through each
structure cognition, and he's really kind
of going deep and kind of recapping what
he's been covering through the previous
the rest of the book.
So for structure, he says, the stronger a
firm's cross hierarchical, top down,
bottom up cognitive throughput coupling
between and within governance and
operational channels, the stronger the
firm's orientation towards free energy.
Surprise minimization based on self
organization.
The less dominant a firm's top down
approach cultivating a form of
Ceocentrism and strategy ownership, the
stronger the sustainability of successful
and continuous strategic renewal and
hence the firm's prospects for survival.
Bleu: Cool, thanks.
And so this is kind of like the punchline
of the structure.
And so I pulled out maybe just a couple
of topics from before the punchline to
talk about.
And so this kind of like top down, bottom
up coupling, I was like looking for a
picture of what does top down, bottom up
coupling look like?
How do you see that?
Can I visualize that?
Actually, I was looking for a picture to
put on the previous slide and I came
across this 2008 paper, from Emotion
Resonance to Empathic Understanding a
Social Developmental Neuroscience
Account.
And my background is neuroscience, but
it's definitely like cellular and
molecular neuroscience.
So I don't really have a good
comprehensive reading of social and
developmental neuroscience and what that
looks like.
And I loved this figure because it just
was so encompassing of so many of the
things that we've talked about so far.
Daniel, have you read this paper?
Have you ever seen this before?
I hadn't either, and I came across the
figure and I was like, oh, I have to get
the paper now.
And so it was nice to kind of just delve
into this and it's really about what's
required for empathy.
And I'll talk more about it.
But here you see like the top down,
bottom up coupling.
So it's bottom up information processing,
top down information processing relation
to relative to the individual and then
the context or situation.
And there's this perception action
coupling in 2008.
I'm like the perception action loop from
2008.
This is cool.
And they talk about shared representation
and this self other awareness, which we
talked about a couple of bookstreams ago,
how distinguishing the self versus the
other self and non self.
So I thought that this was really cool.
And executive functions, regulation and
control metacognition, that's like double
loop learning the metacognition aspect.
So I thought that this paper was really
cool and it really was like, wow, all of
this is grounded in empathy.
Anyway, it was neat, it was a good read.
It's destiny and Meyer, 2008.
And the link is up there if you want the
DOI or any of that stuff.
And it made me think, all of this is
grounded in empathy.
We know, or at least it's thought in
business, that to be successful as a
business person, your emotional potion,
your EQ, is way more important than your
IQ, like your ability to relate to others
and interact with people.
So a good emotional high emotional
quotient versus like an intelligence
quotient is way more crucial to business
success.
And so I just wonder about the
relationship between, if any, between
free energy governance and the emotional
quotient.
Never talked about this directly in the
book, but it just made me think how
important is empathy for this kind of
governance structure?
I don't know if you guys have any
thoughts here on this.
Tyler: Yeah, I think empathy is just
really like sensitivity to your
environment or sensitivity to other
actors and their internal states.
And so in the context of a firm, it
doesn't necessarily need to be like you
could think of an emotion necessarily as
for another firm, maybe the internal
state of this external other firm.
So maybe you are dependent on this other
firm.
Things aren't going the way you would
expect them to go with this other firm.
Maybe orders are backlogged or their API
is being kind of intermittently down.
Maybe that is like a signal into the
internal state of that firm and the
internal state of the ecosystem as well.
And so I think that might be analogous to
an emotion in a human context.
Maybe.
Bleu: They had a bunch of definitions
actually in the paper, and I can't pull
it up because I'm screencasting, so I'm
not going to let you guys go through all
my 25,000 open windows, but maybe we'll
pull them out.
And this is maybe a good question for
Brian about the relationship between
empathy and the free energy governance
when we get to see him next week.
But they had several different
definitions of empathy too in the paper,
which I thought was interesting they
really tried to take a very logical
approach to it and it was cool.
Okay, so here is a claim from the paper.
Bajan says the higher the organizational
friction in terms of obstructing bottom
up error messages, traveling to and
reaching top down prediction generators,
the higher free energy, the potential for
surprise, and the more likely that top
down dominant logics fossilize prediction
models, and hence reinforce a firm's
entropy.
And this is something that maybe Tyler
and I have brought up either on stream,
but we've talked about it off stream a
lot.
How do we reduce this organizational
friction?
Where are the examples that show us what
is the best way to reduce this friction
to create a good top down, bottom up
coupling?
We know that this coupling is super
important, like at all layers across the
hierarchy.
But can we find an empirical way that
works in all situations to build that
structure?
And that, I think, is like a challenge or
maybe a future research question?
Tyler: I guess another thing that is a
little counterintuitive about this too,
is that oftentimes the things that will
reduce friction and maybe like the longer
term, feel high friction in that moment.
So, for example, in previous streams,
we've been talking about dissonance as
being like a way of thinking about that
friction, right?
Well, the easiest way to deal with
dissonance, the lowest friction way you
could deal with it personally is just
like not thinking about it, just like
tunnel vision and just ignore it and
don't worry about these weird feelings
that you have.
But that obviously doesn't help the
friction of the organization as a whole.
And so, yeah, there's this kind of
especially in your personal life too, by
analogy, is like confronting your own
emotions that you don't want to think
about in the short term.
Really easy to just power through and
just keep doing what you're doing.
But if you can process these and
integrate these emotions, that's a lot
healthier for you long term.
So it's an interesting kind of tension
between your individual tendencies of not
wanting friction and friction in the
organization as a whole.
Daniel: Also to connect back to the
thermodynamics.
What is friction?
Well, it's when a force is applied on
some surface or through some media and it
results in heat, which is dissipated,
taking away energy from what could have
been done for work.
And now think about friction
engineering.
Do we coat every object with Teflon?
Do we want everything to just at the
lightest touch, fly off into space?
So just because we can increase or reduce
friction actually doesn't tell us,
especially over time scales like you're
bringing up Tyler, whether we want
something to have a lot of friction, like
where the rubber hits the road or whether
there are some fundamental trade offs
with how much heat the tire is losing in
contact with a smooth road versus how
much grip it has on a loose road.
And so all these different trade offs are
where the actual art and science is going
to come into play.
But friction is not just a term that's
used every day to describe annoying
communication patterns.
Feg is pointing towards that potentially
being understood as an actual physical
force.
Bleu: Cool.
Do you want to read this one for us,
Tyler?
Tyler: Sure.
So, the second proposition cognition.
So the stronger a firm's cognitive
disposition towards environmental
enactment and innovative abduction as
opposed to adaptation.
The stronger the firm's orientation
towards free energy surprise minimization
based self organization the stronger the
firm's strategic control and the smaller
the risk of falling for the financial
control trap, the stronger the
sustainability of successful and
continuous strategic renewal and hence
the firm's prospects for survival.
Bleu: All right.
And so I'm going to read another quote
from this section on cognition, and I
brought back this picture because I think
it's important.
Okay, so Bijean says, cognition in the
form of world enactment is the purpose,
directed, action, centric and social
construction of shared meaning and shared
expectations, anchored in the
understanding that a firm's environment
is a matter of environmental engagement
in the form of interaction, revealing
significance, and assigning probabilities
to a bounded set of external unknown
states.
And so I'm coming back to this paper and
I'm looking at the information
processing, bottom up, top down.
And here I see this shared
representations, and we've seen this in
this figure in this paper.
They're talking about body language.
And somatic response like heart rate
increase or lower and all these things
that have been measured in the generation
of empathy.
But is empathy maybe something that is
required for shared meaning or shared
expectation?
I wonder, do you have to have that?
Is a sociopath, like, devoid of empathy,
like living in a world where things don't
mean the same thing and expectations
aren't the same?
Maybe, right?
There might be a strong link there that I
wonder if it's been explored or not.
So I'm just curious if you guys have
thoughts on what developing shared
meaning and expectation is and if it
requires some kind of empathy with
others.
Tyler: Yeah, I share that feeling.
One of the big questions I've had through
this, and honestly, it's on a personal
level, I've always been interested on
whether you could build tooling that
would help create that shared meaning and
expectations or whether this is really
just constrained by the individual.
If you have people who are sociopaths in
your organization, maybe it's just like
there's certain the way that they're
wired kind of limits the way that they
can engage and create shared meaning with
the rest of the organization.
And so, yeah, I'm kind of curious what
you all think about that too.
I don't have an answer for it, but maybe
that'd be a good question for Sean.
Bleu: All right.
Daniel, thoughts?
No thoughts?
Daniel: Well, to have interpersonal
empathy as a behavior, as a feeling,
that's one whole area.
But in the creation of organizations,
it's almost like we have to ask not how
strongly we feel or what we feel, but
whether some future person in that
organization outside of our direct
perception, cognition action loop is
going to have some sort of outcome.
Because I think it's easy just to sketch
out that you could feel really empathetic
empathetic or any emotional state, and it
could result in a totally discordant
state even for somebody you care about or
vice versa.
So how do we not get lost with just the
introspection of the feeling of empathy
and translate that into systems whose
efficacy is equivalent to what we would
have intended, but that may not feel like
empathy all the time?
Tyler: Yeah, I feel like especially over
the last couple of chapters, we keep
running to a similar concept of theme of
how the individuals wired in terms of
empathy and their ability to create
shared meaning and how that bubbles up
into the rest of the organization.
And yeah, I keep feeling like there's no
way out of like, hey, we're just limited
as humans in our ability to integrate
external information and that limits the
ability of the organization.
But sounds like Daniel was maybe sounding
more optimistic note of like, well,
actually, maybe you can build some maybe
there's tooling and systems you can build
that can have organizational empathy even
if the individual doesn't have it.
Bleu: So that brings to light something
that Daniel and I have talked about
before working on the discussion of
memes, like randomly random insertion,
random plug for the Eco Meme project.
But when you're really thinking about
painting a picture to convey a shared
meaning, we talked about the
echolocation, how the dolphin literally
can paint a picture.
Like, I saw a fish over here and can
translate puts the picture of the fish
into the other dolphin's mind.
Like, there's the picture of the fish,
right?
And so, like you we literally can paint
the entire picture.
So like, even if we could do something as
remarkable as that, we convey only the
semantic content.
If you can say the fire hydrant is red,
right?
And you guys both know can picture in
your mind like a red fire hydrant,
right?
But we don't know what semiotic content
is contained in that message.
Maybe someone's colorblind, maybe they
don't know if it's red or green.
They can't help, right?
And so the fire hydrant just appears in
this gray thing that they think might be
red or maybe someone has been in a house
that burned down and the fire hydrant
didn't work and they have this trauma
inspiration moment, right?
So the semiotic content, the symbolism
behind the message or the picture that
you painted, even in a situation where
you can perfectly create the tooling to
come to this shared meaning or
representation, you're never going to get
the symbolism that exists for someone
else.
It's a highly personal thing.
We can have shared symbolism too,
culturally, for sure, but there's a deep
level of personal symbolism in every
human that's dependent on your previous
life experience, I think.
So coming back to abduction, because we
did talk about it in the section, I can't
remember if it was in the last quote or
not, but I just wanted to point out this
is a recycled slide.
But coming back to abduction, where
Bijean talks about it, is abductive
reasoning.
This is a quote from the book.
Abductive reasoning usually begins with a
surprising observation or experience.
This is what shatters our habit and
motivates us to create a hypothesis that
might resolve the anomaly.
Abduction is an inferential procedure in
which we create a conjecture that if it
would make the surprising anomaly part of
our normal world, of our normal
understanding of the world.
So this picture is, like, the best way
for me to always think about abduction.
You can have a specific observation and
you can come to a general conclusion,
right?
And then you can have deductive reasoning
where you have a general rule, but that
leads to a specific conclusion that's
always true.
And then when you have an incomplete
observation, like, you can't see what's
going on, you just go to the best guess.
And so in Business and Bishop talks about
this again and again and again, you have
to use abductive reasoning, because we're
never going to have a complete picture of
the past and future of the market, like,
the whole market, or even your target
audience.
So you're dealing with the best logical
guess.
Okay.
Do you want to read this one for us,
Tyler?
This is you?
Tyler: Sure.
So the firm's Generative model is the
firm's Econich.
If uncertainty and unpredictability
dominate our worldly perception, well,
then this reflects the very limitations
and corrosiveness of our models and the
underlying processes generating those
models.
There is no objective uncertainty.
There is only your uncertainty.
Environment is enacted.
Each act opens a new fork of multiple
paths, leading to potentially very
different outcomes.
Reality is subjective algorithm applying
an infinite number of worlds.
In superposition.
Our ActInf not only create the junctures
leading to different paths, but we are in
control to decide which path to take at
each juncture.
So, yeah, I thought this really
summarized well, the kind of inactive
cognition.
So there's a song proposition Two here of
Feg.
And also just that was, like, a fun quote
because we talked about a lot in the last
stream, but John's been using kind of
quantum language here, and we talked
about that in the last stream of K.
What exactly does he mean there by that
Bleu?
Daniel, anything to add here?
Bleu: I love your Excel spreadsheet.
Quantum superposition of an Excel
spreadsheet.
Daniel: It's capturing the late night
blurry.
What action selection to take based upon
this spreadsheet?
Great.
Bleu: All right, so Bajan makes this
claim also in this section.
He says, in fact, we are challenged.
Not to allow for the human brain's
conceptual limits to solely determine
perception and sense making, instead
outsourcing some of the heavy
information.
Lifting to the environment in the form of
extended cognition is the essence of
optimizing prediction error
minimization.
The more exponential and hence
discontinuous a market environment, the
more we need self organizing mechanisms
that leverage the world as a supervisory
signal, challenging in circular causality
the very perceptual content of our
predictions.
And so we've talked a lot about cognitive
offloading or extended cognition in terms
of cumulative cultural evolution.
Not in this bookstream per se, but over
the course active inference lab from the
very first beginning live streams.
We've talked about it a lot because now
so much thinking is done externally.
It's encultured at some point with the
smartphone, we don't have to know how to
get anywhere anymore, we'll just map it.
So I just am thinking like this self
organizing mechanisms that leverage the
world as a supervisory signal,
challenging in circular causality the
very perceptual content of our
predictions.
I'm so amazed by Chat GPT.
I'm using it so much just because it's
like what does everybody know?
Chat GPT tells you what everybody knows.
It is like the selective synthesis of all
information, right?
And so if you know something that Chat
Gpt-3 doesn't know, that's great, you can
write a blog about it.
But now Chat GP Three can just write all
the blogs about every other thing.
It knows everything, right?
It's got all of the information synthesis
except the rare pockets of knowledge.
So is this, this self organizing
mechanism, this Chat Gpt-3 like a Global
search synthesis information management
system?
Daniel: I don't know.
Bleu: What do you guys think about that?
Tyler: Well, this is very out of my depth
both in terms of machine learning and
active inference.
But I was thinking about this last night
because this is like a huge debate right
now.
It's like whether Chat Gpt-3 is actually
showing emergent intelligence or whether
it's just like a clever algorithm.
And I was thinking about this too.
Where are the differences between Chat
Gbt Three and what I've been learning so
far about active inference?
And the crucial things that seems to be
missing is like the inactive aspect of
it.
It's not really in dialogue with its
world.
It's like stringing together information
that's like a static, right?
It doesn't even incorporate new
information.
Like if you were to ask it about the news
yesterday, it couldn't do that.
And it's not taking actions in the world
and giving feedback.
It's just like the static model of how
the world works.
And so I don't know, it feels like
fundamentally different to me and I'm not
sure what that means.
I'm not sure if something has to display
active inference to have true
intelligence.
I'm sure this is like a big hotly
contested topic.
I'm sure you guys have many live streams
about this.
Yeah.
Daniel Bleu.
I'm curious what you guys think in.
Daniel: The space of communication, the
response it provides to you is an action
that's not moving, a mechanical arm on a
table.
But in our Internet of everything, it's
not so hard to see how the digital
outputs from a generative algorithm do
translate to physical objects moving.
But it may not even need to do that.
It can send out messages on social media
and definitely meriting further
discussion as things will continue to
develop and gain more access to recent
information, world model learning and
action capacity soon.
Bleu: I have a little bit of a technical
response here.
I think that the question is not about
true intelligence, maybe, but the
question that I hear talked about a lot
is Sentience, right?
But I have read this big article about is
Gpt-3 Sentient?
And I think it was like from one of the
inside Google people, the one that was
released, and now they're talking about
it because everybody's using it.
And Sentient, they just said able to
think and act independently.
But that's not the definition of
Sentient.
I'm not sure what the definition of
Sentient is, but it's not like
autonomous.
They're using Sentient and autonomous the
same way.
And Sentient is like, able to feel
things.
Right?
So I think let's look it up right now.
Let's define Sentient for the world at
large.
What does that mean?
Because intelligent Sentient and
autonomous are all different.
So hold on, I'm looking on my.
Daniel: Phone because I'm screen sharing
words, words humpty.
Alice in Wonderland, people will use
them.
Bleu: How they want, but that's
everything.
So a Sentient is able to perceive or feel
things, right?
And so is Gpt-3 feeling anything?
I highly doubt it perceiving a lot,
sure.
But as to your thing about updating,
Tyler, I'm sure the model will update at
some regular interval.
So just think about we're not there yet
in terms of compute power, but maybe in
ten years it will be training on the
entire Wikipedia catalog every single
day.
So does Wikipedia have a date entry for
every day?
I think it does, right?
So when you ask, what was the news
yesterday, it'll know that that's just a
matter of what's encoded and what's being
processed through silicone.
It's only time, right?
We're way close.
So it will be able to update with some
regularity will it update itself?
I don't know.
That gets into autonomous acting.
All those things are different.
Tyler: That reminds me, though, because
we've had this discussion over the past
15 minutes about empathy and do
organizations have empathy?
And it's kind of like the same
conversation as Gpt-3 of like, okay,
well, maybe organizational empathy, it
looks and just feels differently than
individual empathy.
Right?
And so you can imagine the same thing
happening in Gpt-3.
And I don't know what that version of
empathy would look like in Gpt-3, but
maybe it's just like something that we
can't quite wrap our hands around.
Daniel: It'll be awesome.
Again, I think a further discussion would
be very timely, especially if, for
example, communication from one person's
syntax could move into a semantic space
or a rhetorical space from the eco meme
direction, as Bleu mentioned, and then be
translated back into another semantic
space for the listener.
That might be changing the amount of math
detail or in a different human natural
language.
So there's a lot of incredible
opportunities.
Bleu: Yeah, definitely.
I think it'll be interesting to see to
interrogate Bajan with such esoteric
questions.
With such esoteric questions.
See what he thinks.
Does the firm have empathy?
Where did you even get this?
Well, we got it.
Sorry, we're off to ask anyway.
All right, so moving on.
Tyler, do you want to read this one
proposition?
Tyler: Sure.
So the stronger the board's dmn centric
duality stewardship empowering upper
echelon, sustainably balanced
exploitation versus exploration, as well
as strategic or financial versus
strategic control, the stronger the
firm's orientation towards free energy
surprise minimization based self
organization, the stronger the
sustainability of successful and
continuous strategic renewal and hence
the firm's prospects for survival.
Bleu: Cool.
And so we talked about this last week a
lot.
I didn't put a lot of extra information
in here because we did, like, the
antagonistic neural that perspective last
week, but I did just want to include the
summary.
So Bijean, at the end of the chapter,
summarizes it by saying, in summary, the
board must assume the role of sponsor or
enforcer of three categorical imperatives
defining the success and sustainability
of strategic renewal and firm survival.
First, foster cognitive coupling between
and within all hierarchical layers.
I'm really excited to find out exactly
how to do this.
Second, embrace environment as action
generated and socially constructed shared
meaning and shared expectations, which
we've talked about a lot today.
And third, DeChane the firm from thinking
in terms of antagonisms, but embrace real
time duality management as a critical
determinant of performance and survival.
That's pretty much it.
Do you guys have any final thoughts?
Daniel: The overtime period?
The generative AI speculation moment?
The hashtag 2023?
Questions that we all have.
Bleu: Good times.
So we talked about quantum.
So I'm leaving us with this one quote
from this chapter because it's just kind
of, like, thrown in there.
Bijan says, classical linear cause effect
thinking is no match for quantum
exponentiality.
I wonder what he means by quantum
Like, are we again talking about
superposition or are we talking about,
like, super?
Because that's, like, I guess, the many
states existing at once.
Is that what he means by exponentiality?
What do you guys think?
Tyler: Think Jean has a poetic bent in
him.
Not sure if we're meant to take this
fully literally.
Daniel: Exponents are used in a lot of
quantum mechanics, so there could be
various readings just like any other good
poem.
So we should jump in with these kinds of
questions.
Bleu: Cool.
Well, that's next week.
So, yeah.
Excited to wrap up this part and just a
couple more book streams left for us.
Winding down again.
Get in touch if you would like to
participate in our final discussion.
We would really welcome any external
perspectives.
Daniel: All right, thanks.
See you next time.